واعلن الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني استشهاد
شاب اثرى اطلاق قوات الاحتلال الرصاص عليه
عند حاجز النفق العسكري جنوبي القدس
المحتله كما افادت مراسله الجزيره
باستشهاد فلسطينيين خلال اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه رام الله وذكرت
مراسلتنا ان عدد المصابين ارتفع الى 15
خلال عمليه الاقتحام فقد اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال مدينه رام الله والبيره ودهمت
محل الصرافه واعتقلت عددا من اصحابها
وفاد الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني باصابه خمسه
شبان فلسطينيين برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلال مواجهات عنيفه اندلعت في بلده بيت
ريما شمال غرب رم الله في الضفه الغربيه
وكانت قوات من جيش الاحتلال قد اقتحمت
البلده وسيرت دورياتها وفرقا من المشاه
وداهمت منازل فيها وهو ما ادى الى اندلاع
مواجهات كما وثقت كاميرات المراقبه قيا مع
عدد من جنود الاحتلال بالاعتداء على احد
المصابين قبل ان تنسحب من
البلده